biden's border crisis causing a
free-for-all in america's largest
liberal city hundreds of illegal
immigrants lining up outside a new york
city hospital
bus there by texas governor greg abbott
the city offering migrants free phones
food health care and many are being put
up in 400 a night luxury hotels now
these great perks coming of course
courtesy of the american taxpayer the
new york post summing it up as quote
land of the free but what about the
american citizens who are already here
do they get a handout as well
nope rent prices have been exploding all
across the country one person forced to
pay nearly twenty thousand dollars just
in order to secure
a one-bedroom apartment
so joey i'm going to start with you you
hear all these handouts what's the
message to america's homeless veterans
or families who are struggling and i
mentioned this as well when this whole
border stuff started heating up under
joe biden and i heard they were putting
um illegal migrants inside of barracks i
thought well why haven't we been doing
that with homeless veterans um so what's
the message to the american people when
they see this well it's called
i don't personally equate those two
things because i think there are two
problems with two different route issues
it's easy though to look at that and say
where are your priorities government i
would say that the democrat party would
love to have veterans on on their on
their dime as well so that they can be
pacified and bring their votes in as
well they love any class of americans
they can put into a position where they
need the government to make ends meet
with illegal immigrants though and
that's and that is the root cause of
this issue this problem is so old news i
laugh at it i mean i grew up in a town
in the 90s where this was a problem my
grandfather worked next to an illegal
immigrant every day for seven years that
illegal immigrant paid one dollar in
taxes my grandfather paid a lot more
when the government caught up to him he
left he came back six months later under
a different name and social security
number continued to do the same thing
and that happened over and over again
the infrastructure for fraudulent
identities in this country is a problem
and it's something that the the
government knows about it's something
that in some ways both partisan sides
are complicit in because in the 90s it
was great to have all that cheap labor
well now it's a little bit harder to do
that and so everybody's gotten more
creative but the immigration problem
starts and ends with a government so
dysfunctional that it can't do what most
americans are asking it to do which is
to reform immigration and have a policy
that makes sense and i go back and i
beat this dead horse and that's okay
because dead horses don't feel anything
i beat this dead horse nancy pelosi had
a deal with president trump
to fund the wall and in return get a
codified daca and reforms and visa
applications something the democrats
wanted she didn't take it because she
couldn't give president trump the win
and she knew she might have a chance at
winning in the course what she did on
daca so when you talk about doing what's
best for the people that's always going
to come second for what's best for
partisan politics especially for those
like nancy that are in power and that's
where we are so jesse joey talks about
the politics of it there's also a lot of
money in all of this illegal immigration
there are ngos catholic charities
lutheran charities
um other ngos that are making a lot of
money these hotels are making a lot of
money there's a business behind this
there is if i were a homeless person in
america
i'd be upset because i used to be the
toast of the town in manhattan remember
de blasio was letting me stay in hotels
for free joe was sending me free crack
pipes
i mean i could do pretty much whatever i
wanted i could light the fox news
christmas tree on fire and walk out the
next day from jail no bail
and now all of a sudden
there's like some better looking person
in town that the democrats are just
falling all over uh they're giving them
free health care they're doing
interviews they get the new biden phone
i still stuck with the new the old obama
phone it doesn't even work
i actually saw a homeless guy today on
the upper east side
with a phone
and he was in a sleeping bag it was like
an rei sleeping bag it was a really nice
sleeping bag they shouldn't have all
this kind of stuff so right now the
migrants are like the new victim flavor
of the week and if you're homeless and
you're american i'm sorry go to the back
of the line but if you're a parent in
manhattan i'd be even more angry because
my child you know that was a lost year
during covet and so you're already
behind and now you're putting like five
migrants into your fourth grade
classroom they don't really speak
english don't you think that's going to
slow the lesson plan down yeah i mean
you might get a better soccer team yeah
out of it i'm sure the coaches are
asking abbott to send buses faster
before the season starts um very good
soccer players but but it can't continue
to happen and joe biden can shut this
thing down right now if he wanted to but
you know what he's doing he's building a
fence around his house in delaware so
people don't trespass onto his property
but he'll let anybody else trespass on
the rest of our property i can't believe
no one's asked joe about that just want
you to know i have nine latino kids no
good soccer players what happened
i don't know
maybe when you get a hockey player irish
wisconsin husband something goes wrong
you should actually get it from both
from both sides on that the athletic
ability should be strong we should
probably move on
[Laughter]
all right harold somebody else at the
back of the line so the all of these
services are coming from the city's
immigration affairs office a part of it
some of it's coming from other parts but
you know the other people who are at the
back of the line are those people who
feel like chumps for trying to be
um trying to come here legally who are
following the rules what about them is
this fair to them probably not
i'd say no um what i don't get and joey
i appreciate you differentiating between
some of the and rachel meant no nothing
more than just talking about ways in
which we allocate resources to our
country and you're talking about the
veterans should be treated i don't think
democrats wonder about on the dole but i
do think you're right we should separate
how we think about this
but i don't know what we're trying to
get out here i i think mayor adams uh
and governor abbott had it out a week or
two ago verbally and i think governor
abbott got the better of that exchange
at the beginning and i think mayor adams
is trying to figure out how we how we
grapple and i give him a lot of credit
for saying we're going to help those who
are in need but the question i have is
what is the long-term answer here you
were getting at the long-term answer in
terms of immigration reform but what did
we plan on doing do we just want as
americans busloads of people whom are
crossing the border legally or illegally
to just be shipped around the country on
buses and be integrated into communities
i read this we don't want to cross the
border to begin with what if there was
remain in mexico and they never actually
i'm trying to agree with you but with
the trump trump about the process
i don't get what's going on here and
again i think what we need to do it we
need to build a wall there at the border
with the daca reforms we've talked about
we need an asylum process that is
expedited we need to send more judges
down there to ensure whether it's
remaining mexico or wherever even it
should not just be remain in mexico
she'd be remaining wherever these these
people are from to me the border is a
national security issue
and it's become a humanitarian crisis
because we've allowed it in many ways
and we shouldn't kid ourselves this has
gone on for a long time when i was in
congress her boss dana's boss tried to
negotiate with john mccain trying to
negotiate a a a immigration reform plan
and we've had these things blow up you
know why because each side gets a little
out of this somewhere along the line you
guys
virtue signaled that you guys were
sanctuary cities
and i don't know of any democrat or
republican that believes well what's
busting people across what's the
question
we have a national security practices
he's saying it's the only way to get
democrats to care about this i'm not
faulting it i'm saying this is a
national issue that needs to be
addressed so we got a fox news alert
you're for the wall
here's another problem one migrant told
dana npr that he stayed at a new york
city shelter and he was scared for his
life he told the reporter i'd 1 000
times rather stay in the streets than a
shelter in new york city he called for
the mayor he's one of the ones that
didn't get the four-star hotel he called
for the mayor and the city to offer more
support but he said this was interesting
not just for illegals he called for the
city to take better care of their own
people that are in dire straits okay so
control room don't get mad at me because
i know you said we have to go but i this
is my favorite topic it's my favorite
story of the month it might be my
favorite story of the year because
now you take those two issues
immigration and crime and now you don't
just have hypothetical situations you
have blue cities having to defend the
policies that they like so
now you have to test the fact that the
border is open and now muriel bowser the
mayor of dc is asking for the national
guard she in fact she just asked for
more she originally got turned down now
she's asking for more the washington
post editorial page says today boy the
mayor you've got to really prepare for
this this is really bad but nowhere in
the editorial does it say joe biden and
his administration should do something
different they don't say anything like
build a wall then you have the question
of sanctuary cities oh the sanctuary is
great until it's happening in your
schools and then you have the issue of
the fact that you have free social
services well that sounds really good
until you start to put it into practice
so finally it might not be the right
solution but you're finally changing the
conversation because we are 18 months
into this administration and you have
not had any media cover the story i
don't see how the media covers this
story
they're so worried about the migrants
that are coming here and no one talks
about the fact of how they got here in
the first place it's actually quite an
art that the media is performing right
now
thank you i thought you tied that
together brilliantly thank you and
you're right i thought it was a silly
stunt by abbott i think it was brilliant
it was brilliant
[Laughter]
shooting down efforts to fix the massive
teacher shortage in our country hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now